aware of the high profile reports the
media regarding baroness Moon and her
connection with ppep Metro contact with
government ministers and the use of a
VIP Lane in relation to the procurement
of PPE will the Secretary of State
assure me and more importantly the
public that the full and thorough
investigation will take place into these
matters and that the following that
investigation that report will be made
public thank you well Mr Speaker I can
do much better than that we have
commissioned a full investigation an
inquiry into the government's handling
of covid and as part of that I'm sure
that inquiry will look at our PPE but
it's important to put it in context we
secured 23.2 billion items of PPE and
that was a huge step done at pays to
help protect our front line we don't
come to SMP sportsperson Stephenville Mr
Speaker officials in our high ranking
Associates are great to find Financial
benefits of that deadly disease
shamelessly profit here in public funds
the SNP has long sought to highlight the
rampant cronyism and Corruption of this
government this PPE plundering is the
most egregious case we've seen so far
and then Scott on the Scottish
government has robust procedures in
place to ensure protection of
procurement and health care so how well
the Secretary of State better regularly
regulate against the colonialism of his
colleagues and where we come out now to
scrap in the UK government's VIP Reign
for Health Care contracts in here but
again Mr Speaker it ignores about the
pressure of time at the start of the
pandemic and also the fact that this was
an international competition with
countries competing for very scarce
resources it is also the case that over
19 000 companies were offering PPE only
2 600 Mr Speaker passed initial due
diligence checks we now come to Andy
Factor very much for speaker number two
please thank you Mr Speaker to support
operational resilience this winter the
NHS has set out plans to increase
hospital bed capacity by the equivalent
of at least seven thousand General and
acute beds during winter this is
alongside 500 million pounds of funding
to support quick safe discharge from
hospital and free up capacity and 1.5
billion pounds of targeted investment
funding for new surgical hubs increasing
bed capacity and equipment for elective
care recovery Andy Carter thank you Mr
Speaker I'm very grateful for The
Minister's response there over the last
20 years Warrington has had some of the
highest level of new houses built in the
northwest of England but our Healthcare
infrastructure hasn't kept pace we
desperately need a new hospital our a e
is at breaking point we don't have
enough beds and there's nowhere to park
your car when you go and visit
in 2021 my NHS trust submitted a bid to
the NH to the Department of Health for a
new hospital could you give us an update
on where we are with that process
well I thank my normal friend he's been
a long-standing advocate for a new
General Hospital for Warrington the
expression of Interest has been received
from the trust and we are currently in
the process of reviewing expressions of
interest for the eight new hospitals and
aim to announce a final decision by the
end of the year I recently met with my
honorable friend to hear about the plans
and Mr Speaker the people of Warrington
could not have a greater Champion than
my normal friends direct to it
conception can I associate the remarks
with the honorable gentleman from
Warrington South about the need for
investments in the Warrington of Halton
Hospital trust and it's important that
both hospitals have that investment team
but can I say to the minister that part
of the problem with capacity is the lack
of social care uh capacity in in in the
community whether that's in a home or
with whether it's in the in the the
patient's own home just recently I had a
an email from the chief executive of
Western Hospital which is a larger coach
hospital where 115 patients Mr Speaker
would embed they did not need know if I
should be going out of the hospital out
of a total of 721 acute beds I got the
cute beds isn't this just an example
where the government is actually failing
to provide enough social occur out in
the community
well Mr Speaker investing the 500
million pounds to create another 200 000
social care placements but we have
significantly increased the number of
physical beds available in our hospital
so in July before we made the commitment
to increase bed capacity we had 96
375 General and acute beds compared to
97 350 in October and we're also
delivering that increased capacity
outside of hospital so this winter
creating an extra two and a half
thousand virtual Ward beds Chris jobs
thank you Mr Speaker does my friend
agree with me that it is high time that
the outstanding care and skill of the
staff at Hillingdon Hospital were
matched by commensurate outstanding
facilities and therefore it is great
news that hittingdon is one of the 14
new hospitals the government is building
by 2030. and can he confirm that the
full funding package will be announced
soon so that the whole uh project can
proceed as soon as possible yeah well I
thank my writable friend for his
question I know the Secretary of State
visited Hillingdon Hospital over the
summer it's the hospital I am also aware
of Mr Speaker there has been no greater
champion of hillington hospital but more
broadly of the new hospitals program
that my right Uncle friend Mr Speaker
currently five Hospital schemes are in
contract construction two are now
completed and we aim to announce the
next eight by the end of this year Sarah
champion
thank you Mr Speaker two weeks ago a
five-year-old constituent of mine Yusuf
Nazir died because we no longer have
intensive pediatric beds in Rotherham
September saw a record-breaking
ambulance Handover delays and the
proportion of patients waiting more than
12 hours in a e Rose to 13.8 percent
nearly double last September's figure
in the last 12 years we've seen
rotherham's NHS being hollowed out what
is the minister going to do to reverse
this
firstly let me thank the old lady for
her question I'm very sorry to hear
about the case that she highlights and I
understand she's written to the
Secretary of State on this issue
ambulance waiting times Mr Speaker are
not where we want them to be and we have
increased ambulance staff by 40 since
2010 we've invested another just under 5
000 more staff in NHS one by one at 111
sorry 2 500 more staff in call centers
an extra 450 million pounds last year
into a e departments and we've created
the 500 million pound discharge fund
which would include improve flow through
hospitals and then of course that extra
7 000 extra beds this winter we
understand the system is under
considerable pressure I'd be very happy
to meet young lady to discuss the
challenges in her own trust Shadow
Minister Dr Alan Khan
thank you very much Mr Speaker the
current state of mental health treatment
sees increasing numbers of people
languishing on waiting lists becoming
more and more unwell
1.1 million adults denied treatment
children stuck in emergency departments
for days waiting for mental health beds
is the government proud that a systemic
cutting of a quarter of NHS mental
health beds over the last 12 years has
led to more patients receiving treatment
in private settings and as the Secretary
of State know how much money is given to
private Mental Health Providers and does
the government honestly think they're
getting good value for money
well Mr Speaker this is not my director
area of responsibility but of course
mental health does present challenges
for accidents and emergency and
hospitals more generally we are
investing in extra 2.3 billion pounds
every year extra extra on Mental Health
we have 16 percent more staff we have an
additional bursary Mr Speaker to attract
more people nurses into mental health
but we do recognize the challenges and I
know my honorable friend the member for
Lewis is working hard to address them
it's definitely
Mr Speaker
uh thank you Mr Speaker reducing waiting
times for Diagnostics and treatment is a
priority for this government the
delivery plan for tackling the elective
backlog sets out steps to recover and
transform outpatient services across all
specialisms including neurology
speaker in March 2021 my constituents
suffered a severe head injury by the
time they have their first neurology
appointment in January 2023 they are
waited nearly two years for treatment in
the meantime they have been able unable
to work rejected and disability benefits
and are in severe pain does the means to
accept that this weight is unacceptable
and can she outline what support the
department is making available for those
who are suffering whilst they wait for
Vital appointments
well I think the honorable lady I know
she raised her constituents case in
Westminster Hall debate on the 22nd of
November and my understanding is that
they now have an appointment uh for
January but there is absolutely a a
backlog from covid uh patients we know
that that's why we're putting over eight
billion pounds over the next three years
to deal with that backlog and that's in
addition to the two billion pounds we've
already provided through the electric
elective Recovery Fund we've already
eliminated virtually the two-year wait
and we are now on track by April to
eliminate those waiting for 18 months or
or more
Issue Number Four Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker I would like to
thank all those who work in Social care
for what they do day in and day out for
people whose lives depend on care we're
supporting Care Homes and agencies in
their efforts to recruit staff including
with a substantial National recruitment
campaign in fact colleagues may have
seen some of the adverts while watching
popular programs like I'm a celebrity we
have also added social care workers to
the shortage occupation list so that
social care can benefit from
International recruitment to increase
the workforce in the short term
um a recent report from the motor
neurone Disease Association outlined at
the mnd appg which I chair
found that most unpaid mnd carers
provide over 75 hours of care per week
but many are unable to access respite
services due to the lack of adequately
skilled care workers equipped to care
for the complexity of mnd sufferers
needs
will the minister commit to increasing
specialized training from conditions
like mnd within the social care
Workforce to protect carers own health
and well-being yeah
well my honorable friend makes an
important point I too have heard from
family carers about the difficulties
they have faced in getting skilled
professional help which in turn gives
them support and respite at the moment
we provide 11 million pounds annually
for Workforce Development Fund Which
social care employers can access to help
pay for staff training and looking ahead
we're working on social care Workforce
reforms of which training and skills
will form a substantial part and I will
commit to looking into his suggestion
that specialist training for mnd care
should be part of this Tim Farrell
speaker in The Lakes we have a problem
with social care being that all other
people working in the care industry are
phenomenal and talented and dedicated
our average age the population is 10
years above the national average
therefore the number of people needing
to be cared for is greater and the size
of the workforce is smaller undoubtedly
poor pay poor conditions and lack of
career prospects are a major problem in
recruiting and retaining the Care staff
that we have but we also have an extra
special problem in our area because with
the absence of indeed the evaporation of
the long-term private rented sector
which is where the carers normally would
have lived will she talk to her
colleagues in the department for
leveling up to make sure we have a
comprehensive package for communities
like mine in Cumbria so we have
well-paid carers and places for carers
to be able to afford to live
yeah I Thank The Honorable member for
his question he makes really really
important points two things I'll say to
him firstly in the short term for the
500 million that were supporting social
care with during this winter the
discharge fund that will go into
increasing capacity in Social care and
indeed dressing some of the addressing
some of the workforce challenges in
areas like his in the long term we're
bringing forward social care reforms
including in Workforce and I recognize
one of the things we need to look at is
making sure there's housing available
for the social care Workforce it's a bow
Mr listen to the minister talking about
increased social care I don't recognize
that in my area Northampton General
Hospital which is one of the hospitals
that served my constituency has around
150 patients a days who could be
medically discharged but can't be this
is 19 of the beds at the same time West
North Hampshire council is closing
spinningfields a 51 bed step down
facility in my constituency yet they
have a PFI contract and for the next
seven years they'll be paying 700 000
pounds for an empty building how can
that be right well the minister sort it
out
well I will take away and look into the
specific example here said in his
constituency because what I want to see
is increased capacity and step-down care
and social care during this winter and
Beyond but particularly during this
winter supported by a fine Broad and
million pounds discharge fund which
we're going to areas like his and across
the country to help make sure that
people who don't need to be impossible
can be out of Hospital getting the care
they need great job Mr Speaker when will
this new health Team wake up to the fact
that many of the things we've been
discussing already this morning but
particularly social care will only be
sold by just treating local authorities
as friends and our lives and partners
rather than the enemy please could we
have action to make local authorities
full Partners delivering every sort of
care yeah
set up integrated Care Systems which
bring together Health and Social care
500 million discharge fund I've been
talking about in fact is allocated to
local areas to be pooled into better
care fund to be spent jointly between
local Authority and the NHS secondly
though funding is an important part of
this in the Autumn statement social care
received a historic fundal funding
settlement of 7.5 billion over the next
two years so that's important as well as
clearly hand-in-hand NHS and local
authorities working together
question number five
uh thank you Mr Speaker we held a
successful call for evidence for a new
cancer plan earlier this year which
received 5 000 responses we're now
considering those responses and how we
can best support the diagnosis treatment
of cancer patients I will be a position
to update the house uh shortly
I thank the minister for her response
but it's been five months since the
10-year cancer plan was due to be
published in July it's been 10 months
since the war encounter was announced in
February and while government has
delayed counter patients have been
facing unacceptable waiting time for
diagnosis and treatment performances for
the 62-day wait between a GP referral
versus better counter to First treatment
over the last five months has been the
worst five on record I say that very
respectfully until the minister but
doesn't Minister agree that what we
really need now is host needs and the
people in this country need is a
long-term and ambitious plan to reduce
these weights and to ensure that cancer
patients in this country have the best
outcomes possible and will the minister
set out a timeline not just say shortly
set at a timeline for delivering to
supply
uh well I can't comment uh as the
honorable Judge will know on what's
happening in Northern Ireland because
health is devolved matter I can only
update on what's happening in England
and we are not waiting for a cancer plan
to start on the backlogs that's why this
government is investing eight billion
pounds over three years to clear the
elective backlog and we are seeing
record numbers of patients Cancer
Treatments continued uh throughout the
pandemic but we are seeing a higher
number than usual uh coming through
we've seen over 129 increase in patients
getting urgent GP referrals uh compared
to September 19 but despite that we are
seeing 91 of patients in England
receiving their treatment with 31 days
of a decision to treat compared to in
June just 87 of patients in Northern
Ireland so I would suggest while we are
very very committed to reducing that
cancer wait time he may wish to speak to
the minister in Northern Ireland as well
I get through speaker with diagnostic
activity whether in Vivo or in vitro
forming part of over 85 percent of
clinical Pathways or mountable friend
confirmed that due recognition of this
will be reflected in the 10-year cancer
strategy
well can I thank my honorable friends
for all her hard work as her time as a
health Minister and absolutely we are
going through the responses right now
and as as I indicated already we will
update the house uh shortly but I will
very much take our points on board the
Meg her there thank you
thank you speaker Michael Jesse who's 24
was diagnosed with the type of brain
cancer grade 4 glyburlastoma multiforma
um this is devastating to her she has
had a very difficult year of treatment
but crucially after her initial round of
treatment there were delays with her
being able to access a scan due to the
backdrops in the NHS and the real need
for a proper Cancer Care plan to make
sure that she gets her scans as
regularly as necessary as other patients
need it as well hers was two months
later than the standard of care leaving
her in absolute fear and Terror that her
cancer would come back and and that fear
is as almost as bad as the disease
itself so what plans does the minister
got to make sure that the 10-year cancer
plan really gets to grips with this
backlog which is devastating people's
lives yeah well I'm sorry to hear about
the experience of their constituent and
I'm sure she'll welcome the 91 Community
diagnostic Centers that have been set up
already to provide a range of tests
without CTS ultrasounds MRIS we're
expecting to deliver up to 160 of these
Community diagnostic Centers in total
with capacity for up to 9 million more
scans uh per year when they're fully
operational this will not just deal with
a backlog but will future proof our
diagnostic services going forward the
Caroline dining Mr Speaker the minister
will know that cancer is the biggest
cause of death for children under the
age of 14 and there are countless
incidents of failure and missed
opportunity in how we detect how we
treat and how we care for children with
cancer I'm really grateful to her
earlier this year meeting my constituent
Charlotte Farrell who tragically lost
her daughter Sophie but does she agree
with me that we need a Childhood Cancer
Mission embedded in the heart of any
cancer strategy if we're serious about
saving fat other families from that
tragedy
well can I thank my right honorable
friends for all her hard work in this
space we did have a debate on the floor
of this house on childhood cancers which
she led and I was delighted to meet her
constituent Charlotte who's campaigning
so hard on this issue and I did promise
her we would look at a cancer a child
cancer Mission as part of that and we
will be updating the house shortly on
our progress okay blue thank you Mr
Speaker my constituent who is a
full-time GP in her 50s told me the pet
oh sorry question number five
speaker
um her question was about the
recruitment of 6000 GPS just uh to
remind the house there were nearly 2 300
more full-time equivalent doctors in
general Practice in September and over
9000 GP trainees in September 2022 both
gambling I'll pick up where I I left off
Mr Speaker she's a full-time a gpn of
50s she told me the pension rules I mean
she either has to retire work part-time
or emigrate which is hardly going to
help her patients to get appointments
with her after hinting of a change on
doctor's pensions this summer the
government is only now announcing a
consultation that will last until next
spring so there's going to be no change
in these crazy doctor pensions rules
until next summer at the earliest is
this not too little too late
yeah well it's personally in terms of
the the numbers it's worth reminding the
house there's three percent more doctors
this year than last year we've got over
two thousand more 300 more uh full-time
doctors in general practice and as I say
we are recruiting more on the point of
pension she's absolutely right that that
is a material issue that is why we have
launched the consultation and we're
working with treasury colleagues uh to
address those concerns as quickly as
possible
Virginia Crossman thank you
thank you GP numbers are falling in
Wales Healthcare in Wales is devolved to
the Welsh labor government and despite
honest more being represented by five
members of the center thing Cardiff
Healthcare concerns represent a
staggering 25 of my post bag does the
Secretary of State agree with me that
families right across Wales are not
getting the health care they need and
deserve from the Welsh labor government
well I do agree with my uh on Wheel
friend and and indeed I think one of the
things that would help the house in
terms of looking at the performance of
the Welsh government if there was more
transparency so for example if you look
at the opposition day motion today which
talks about vacancies in England Mr
Speaker I'm sure it will surprise the
house to know that the Welsh government
stopped collecting Workforce vacancies
statistics in 2011 I look forward to the
bench opposite encouraging their Welsh
colleagues to be more transparent
gentlemen is to a very old work
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker members
across the house will have been shocked
and appalled by the recent deaths of
children from strep a and I thought so
with all those families affected cases
are on the rise and as we head into
winter it is vital that parents are able
to get their children the care they so
desperately need the shortage of GPS
means too many are struggling to see a
doctor and we are now seeing reports of
shortages of antibiotics too so what
advice can the minister give parents if
their children are exhibiting symptoms
but they can't get the GP appointment
and what assurances can they give on the
supply and availability of antibiotics
yeah yeah so so The Honorable lady does
raise an important issue and I know it
is one that is concerning to many
families across the country and it's
therefore helpful to be able to just
reassure the house in terms of our
response on that and firstly whilst GPS
are important
so our directors of Public Health and
they are leading the response in areas
including the liaison with schools we
are seeing an earlier Peak than usual in
terms of cases uh these cases and we
believe this is due to lower exposure
during the pandemic which is then meant
to lower immunity there is no new strain
um and and that I think is one of the
key points in terms of reassurance but
the UK Health security agency has
declared a National Standard and that
enables them to better coordinate our
response including across schools I
learned Colburn question seven Mr
Speaker
Thursday
and the government is committed Mr
Speaker as we heard a moment earlier two
are 40 new hospitals uh programmed by
2030. that is why we have committed that
is why we have committed 3.7 billion
pounds over well
he'll get a go in a moment so I I look
forward to I look forward to him
welcoming the increasing Capital
spending that this government
and in fact that's an increase not just
on our new hospitals program but also on
things like the electives the 5.6
billion into more surgical hubs and CDC
centers but we are committed and that
obviously sits alongside the 1.7 billion
pound of funding that has gone into over
70 hospitals in terms of delivering
significant upgrades Nick Colburn Mr
Speaker Castleton and Wellington
patients will benefit massively from
building a new hospital in Sutton and
improving sent Helia under NHS plans
approved by this government
um Can the right how can my writing a
friend agree to meet with me and the NHS
trust because the trusts are raring to
go to get Spades in the ground next year
Mr Smith I know they're raring to go
because I personally have spoken to the
chief exec about this scheme but I can
offer him something better the minister
of State for health will personally be
visiting shortly in order to discuss
this further but I also need to be
transparent with the house we are
fundamentally changing how we are going
to be building hospitals and the NHS
estate into
I'm not sure why something is important
Mr Speaker
as new hospitals learning from the
Department for education and the
ministry of Justice through a more
standardized muscle model which allows
us to deliver more of the cheaper unit
price and get those built quicker it is
a source of Mirth to the bench opposite
but it's important that we standardize
those designs and that is what my
colleague the minister of state will be
discussing with him to learn Ben thank
you very much indeed Mr Speaker the new
children's hospital the new adult
building and the maternity Center at
Leeds General infirmary will bring much
needed new facilities to leads the
region and wider economic benefits it's
unusual amongst the hospital building
schemes as the secretary of state knows
the site is clear and the plans are
ready so could I urge you to give the
go-ahead as soon as possible yeah yeah
well again Mr Speaker I have visited
that scheme I did so over the summer he
will know that the costs have inflated
significantly since is what was signed
up by the treasury in 2019 and I think
the point that has been missed by the
front bench opposite is the way we
deliver these schemes is to grip better
the cost by using standardization that
is what I will be discussing weird leads
General because I agree with him it is
important that scheme goes ahead and we
need to work together to ensure that it
does at a price that is Affordable
speaker yeah Mr Speaker in July we made
some initial changes to the reform
system to spot NHS Dentistry we invested
an extra 50 million we reformed the
contract to create more UDA bands to
better reflect the fair cost of work
introduce the minimum UDA to help
practices where they're low and allow
dentists to deliver 110 of their udas to
deliver more treatment the number of
dentists doing NHS work last year was up
2.3 percent but we're working on plans
to go further Scott bent thank you Mr
Speaker the change is made to the dental
contract last week where was step in the
right direction but fall some way short
of the holistic reform that is required
to help the estimated 25
000 of my constituents who do not yet
have an NHS dentist will the minister
consider a change whereby the NHS funds
subsidies to underprivileged areas such
as Blackpool thereby allowing NHS
practice to offer a greater Financial
incentive to attract new dentists into
those areas
absolutely Mr Speaker my honorable
friend and I have actually talked about
this and we are looking urgently at
payment models and measures to address
areas which are struggling to attract
the right Workforce the commissioning of
Dentistry will be coming down to more
accountable local level in April we need
to build on that very clear
thank you Mr Speaker my constituents in
Durham have told me Tales of DIY
Dentistry missing teeth children in pain
and the unfairness of only being able to
access dental care if they can afford to
go things shouldn't be this way and the
BDA do not accept that the government's
new plans go far enough to hold the
Decay and NHS Dentistry provision so
will the minister tell me when they will
put in adequate
funding and reform so people in Durham
can get the dental care that they need
and deserve
as well as increasing the number of
dentists doing NHS work and increasing
the amount of work being done and we are
of course taking further steps to uh to
look for longer term and build NHS
Dentistry the number of dental school
places up from 810 in 2019 to 970 in
2021 but of course we want to go further
and we make it easier to have dentists
to come to the UK and practice in fact
we laid a draft secondary legislation on
the of October to give the general
dentistry Dental Council more
flexibility to do that and around the
country plans are advancing for centers
for dental development to additionally
provide not just dentists but also
hygienists and other nurses number nine
so
with permission Mr Speaker I'll answer
this in question 18
um together we're taking action on
public health across the board the three
billion pounds of investing in a drug
strategy will create an extra fifty
thousand extra places in drug treatment
with double duty on cigarettes since
2010 and brought in a minimum excise tax
we're going to have the lowest smoking
rate on record we'll go further the 300
million that we're investing in stock
for life means new or expanded family
hubs in 75 local authorities and we're
taking action right across government
from the 55 billion that we're investing
in energy support to the measures that
we're taking through at the moment to
crack down on non-decent housing thank
you Gibson thank you Mr Speaker leveling
up is not just about jobs and
infrastructure but it's about healthcare
too and Dentistry is a key part of that
however Darlington faces the potential
closure of his surgery serving 7 000
patients because the current system of
NHS Dentistry makes the business case
for that surgery unviable what will my
right honorable friend do to ensure that
we level up dental services so that my
constituents can get the service is that
they need
Mr Speaker my honorable friend and I
have discussed this in actually due to
meet again shortly and I repeat my offer
to speak both to that practice and also
to local Partners so we can tackle The
crucial problem that he has raised
hey Robinson thank you Mr Speaker
research by the University of Manchester
adds to the significant body of evidence
that points that says that addressing
disparities in health care is key to
leveling up
inequalities have resulted in a 30
percent productive productivity Gap in
the north which can be attributed to
poorer Health come our honorable friend
outline how the government is working to
address this and ensure that residents
of the north are not at a Health and
Care disadvantage
speaker I saw that very important report
and I think the answer is that we have
to tackle the problem from both the
health and the economic ends spending on
Health in the north group from 36.5
billion in 2018 19 to 52.6 billion in
2020 so there's a really significant
investment in health and prevention of
ill health uh in the North in terms of
economic activity instead of stopping
people sliding into a cycle of ill
health and worklessness we are jointly
working with the DWP to rule out more
disability employment advisors and job
centers but the underlying key is to
tackle and prevent in health hence the
measures that I mentioned the 3 billion
pounds for the drug strategy the
measures on smoking and the measures on
energy and on housing
to speak up I'll give you a very good
example of Health inequality until quite
recently we used to have a perfectly
good consultant-led maternity service
based in cafenest but following the
Scottish government rubber stamping
decisions pregnant mothers now have to
make a 200 mile return journey to
Inverness to give birth that's a
grounding inequality and it is
Despicable and I hope that Her Majesty's
government will share best practice in
terms of tacting this problem with the
Scottish government
it's always been to work constructively
with the Scottish government it does
sound like a very serious problem
honorable friend has set out how we're
using health spending Capital spend more
efficiently that sounds like an example
where that's not happening unfortunately
in case hello Morgan
Mr Speaker it's been well documented
that people in rural areas have worse
Health outcomes than people in urban
ones and one of the drivers behind that
is a lack of access for the most
vulnerable people to be able to get to
the services they need so with the
minister consider working with his
colleagues in the department of
transport to figure out how we can
provide the services we need for the
most vulnerable people to access the
health care they need yeah yeah
so this is why we are ruling out those
Community diagnostic Centers to bring
Services closer to those who need it
it's also why we are investing in
general Practice in the extra two
thousand twenty one thousand and 200
extra people working in general practice
to make sure that rural Services as well
as service unless the country are also
improved
in 2019 the Tories promised to extend
healthy life expectancy by five years
but on this Mr Speaker they are failing
in the last year the health disparities
white paper has disappeared the Tobacco
Control plan has been delayed and
they've chickened out of implementing
the Obesity strategy because the prime
minister is too cowardly to stand up to
his back benches and health inequalities
are widening as a consequence so does
the minister plan on Reviving any of
these strategies or have the
conservatives now completely given up on
prevention
I've already talked about some of the
things we're doing to crack on with
improving public health and our
inequalities but let me add some more
we're also driving up blood donations
for shortage groups we're driving up
vaccine uptake in the areas that is
lowest I mentioned already the extra 900
million pounds we're putting into drug
treatment taking a total of three
billion pounds of investment over three
years I won't repeat all the things I've
already mentioned but we are across the
board working at PACE to improve public
health and narrow those Health
inequalities
Mr Speaker
immediate PR doubles or quadruple
survival from an out of Hospital cardiac
arrest and defibrillation within three
to five minutes dramatically improves
the chance of survival that's why NHS
England is establishing a network of
defibrillators and Community First
Responders which aims to save up to 4
000 lives a year by 2028. thank you Mr
Speaker and average 150 people a day die
from certain Cardiac Arrest outside of
hospitals access to defibrillatos is
crucial for survival rates without one
the chance is surviving drop by 10 every
minute I welcome the government
commitment to roll out defibrillators
across state-funded schools in England
and Wales but shared concerns that
because of significant ongoing supply
chain issues this may not be achieved
can the minister explain how the
department is helping to reach the
target of supplying 20 000
defibrillators by 2023
uh well as the honorable member says
access to a defibrillator makes a great
difference to the prospects of survival
for somebody having a sudden cardiac
arrest and that usually happens either
at home or at the workplace most
commonly since May 2020 the government
has required all new school builds and
refurbishments to have defibrillators
installed I'm very happy to look into
the concern that she raises about that
and get back to her I'm also working on
other initiatives to make sure that we
get more defibrillators into public
places rapidly like many of my
Lincolnshire constituents I live in a
remote Village and there's no Prospect
in the unlikely event that I have a
sudden Cardiac Arrest I'm sure that
would disappoint people there's no
Prospect there's no Prospect of
ambulance coming within 10 15 or even 20
minutes I would have thought the
government could make itself really
popular in real rural areas by having a
massive campaign to roll out
defibrillators in most Villages for
instance all those red telephone boxes
will now be here closing down that would
be a good opportunity put the
defibrillator in one of those
well again my honorable friend makes a
very important Point that's exactly
exact there is work going on at the
moment to increase the number of
defibrillators across the community for
instance in villages such as his own uh
as he as he talks about many villages
will already have them we're also
supporting the NHS to train Community
First Responders to make sure there are
people all across the community have the
skills to do CPR and user defibrillators
and I do look forward very shortly to be
able to announce a new initiative which
will mean further defibrillators across
our communities
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker we are already
putting social care reforms into
practice for instance we want care
providers to adopt digital care records
and over 50 percent have already done so
and I'm determined to shine more light
on our social care system so our new CQC
LED Assurance of local authorities
social care duties is going to start in
April
from West thank you very much Mr Speaker
one of the worst vacancy rates across
the NHS is that of geriatricians what
urgent action is she putting in place to
ensure that people in Social care
settings either at home with domiciliary
care or in Social care settings are
seeing a geriatrician consultant
regularly and if there is a shortage
which I believe that there is what
action is she taking to have more
doctors trained as geriatricians yeah
uh well the honor remember makes an
important point about when people are
receiving social care the importance
that they also have access to the health
care they need and these systems working
together across our health and uh social
social Care Systems we are training more
doctors overall and we have an increase
in medical school school places which is
leading to more doctors coming through
I'm very happy to take away looking
specifically at the question about the
numbers of geriatricians that she raises
Mr Speaker when it comes to delivering
social care reform will my right
honorable friend agree with me that we
also need to be looking at how the
funding packages work particularly
across borders I have a specific case of
a constituent Mr Speaker that for whose
case Falls between two local authorities
would my right honorable friend agree to
meet with me as a matter of urgency to
make sure this poor constituent receives
the funding that she needs for Health
and Care
well as announced in the Autumn
statement we have announced a record
funding settlement for social care of
7.5 billion going into the social care
system over the next two years to
improve both access and quality of care
I'm very happy to meet her and to look
into the specific challenge that she has
because it is important that we have
local areas working together across
boundaries
thank you Mr Speaker look let's just
tell it like it is on the government's
record on social care reform their cap
on care costs was first promised 10
years ago in 2015 They delayed it and in
2017 scrapped it in 2019 the right
honorable member for Uxbridge again
promised to fix the crisis in Social
care but last month the chancellor
buried the policy once and for all after
12 long years what have members opposite
got to show on social care the highest
ever staff vacancies Millions left
without the care they need hospitals
full of people who don't need to be
there and families picking up the strain
isn't the truth on social care just as
with our economy transport housing and
schools they've run out of excuses run
out of Road and the country deserves a
change
[Music]
well we have indeed delayed our social
care chartering reforms because we
listen to the system and we heard local
authorities asking for more time to
repair and then importantly we have
allowed local authorities to keep the
money allocated to that in in their bank
accounts to fund some of the current
pressures on social care but what I will
also ask her to recognize is the record
fundal funding settlement for social
payment 7.5 billion pounds for social
care over the next two years but she
hasn't even acknowledged coupled with
the fact that we're pressing full steam
ahead with our system-wide reforms to
social care supported by over a billion
funding to support the workforce support
the Innovations in Social care and to
transform the quality and access of
social care across the country James
World we'll keep going don't worry 12.
please sir
I had it as number 13 but given the the
question I can guess it's related to the
uh the build of uh the King's Lynn
hospital I visited that site
um and looked at that scheme over the
summer I made clear in a speech I gave
to the NHS providers that addressing the
concerns of the Iraq hospitals is my
number one priority obviously I cannot
comment on individual schemes whilst the
process is ongoing but I can assure him
uh we are working actively on it
thank you Mr Speaker I'd warmly welcome
the priority that my Rumble offenders
put on resolving the serious rat
concrete issues at the Queen Elizabeth
hostel but a decision on this was due in
the spring well Christmas is coming and
the only question people in Northwest
Norfolk have is when we get the present
that everyone wants of a new hospital
for the staff and patients
well I know the uh the extensive support
he has amongst parliamentary colleagues
including my writing my friend the
member for Southwest Norfolk who has
recently added her support uh to the
scheme he'll also be aware that we
allocated 20 million last year and 30
million uh this year to address some of
the immediate issues but we recognize it
is a priority and we are working on it
so Greg die
number 13 sir and Mr Speaker as well as
making it more attractive to practice in
the NHS the number of dental school
places is up from 810 in 2019 to 970 in
2021 will make it easier for qualified
dentists to come to the UK and we're
putting through address secondary
legislation at the moment on that I'm
also encouraging new centers for dental
development
so Greg is the minister aware that there
is a particular problem in Bridlington
in my constituency where an increasing
number of residents are not only finding
it difficult to access NHS dental care
they're finding it impossible to do so
and that recently a dental practice in
the town has closed down so will he
agree to meet with me on this matter to
see what can be done to resolve the
issue hopefully sooner rather than later
Mr Speaker of course I'd be uh very keen
to meet to try and address those issues
and to build on the work that we're
doing nationally Rachel Moscow thank you
Mr speaker York's had a dental desert
for years six years now to see an NHS
dentist and the governments have made no
change to improve that situation
including bringing in more NHS centers
into my area in the light in March
Dentistry will be moving into ics's and
icbs how are they going to solve the
problem
one of the problems has been that having
large remote Regional commissioning for
Dentistry has meant it's more unlikely
that specific local problems will be
picked up and that is why we are taking
the step that she has described she's
now complaining about it even though
it's a measure to get more kind of local
accountability over the way that
services are commissioned title Fabrica
thank you Mr Speaker question 14.
the department has commissioned NHS
England to develop a long-term Workforce
plan this plan will help ensure we have
the right numbers of Staff including
doctors with the right skills to deliver
high quality services fit for the future
this plan will be independently verified
we funded 1500 more Medical School
places in England and opened five new
medical schools in Sunderland Lancashire
Chelmsford Lincoln and Canterbury and
there are record numbers of medical
students in training Mike Republic well
I thank my honorable friend for his
answer he will know that it takes five
or six grueling years to get a Bachelor
of medicine or Bachelor and Bachelor of
surgery degree or doctor of medicine in
Scotland but many students having then
graduated think that they would prefer
the more structured development of their
lives by working as Hospital doctors
what can we do to encourage young
graduates to go into general practice
well I thank my honorable friend face
question we've got record numbers going
into general practice this is the remit
of my honorable friend the member for
Harbor but part of the plan is to make
it more attractive so practice
improvements do things like cloud-based
telephony things like the arrs scheme
the extra 24 000 extra staff in Primary
Care developing multi-function stuff so
people can develop their skills have
specialism but still practice as a a gp2
increasing the use of Pharmacy movement
more towards continuity of care and of
course the new GP contract for 24.25.
thank you Mr Speaker but when are we
going to see the workforce plan because
I spoke to a radiologist who runs a
radiology department the other day
they're meant to be 15 they've only got
five and they've not had a single person
apply and they need more Radiologists
radiographers we've got a national
shortage of dermatologists which is one
of the reasons that skin cancers aren't
being picked up we've got a national
shortage of Pathologists and
histopathologists we really need a
dramatic increase in the number of
people working in the NHS when are we
going to see that Workforce plan I think
my rightful friend for his uh question
as I said we've committed to publish a
comprehensive Workforce strategy which
the chancellor set out will be
independently verified that will be soon
we've set out new pension flexibilities
but Mr Speaker it's important to point
out we have 29 000 more nurses we're on
track to meet our 50 000 Target we've
got 3 700 more doctors compared to last
year 9100 extra nurses and of course 2
300 more GPS
topical number one Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we know that women can
benefit from more personalized care
especially in pregnancy the tummy's app
is a new clinical decision tool for the
NHS and for women another example of how
we're using artificial intelligence to
improve our maternity system that will
help end some of the variation in
maternity care from hospital to hospital
and I'm pleased to tell honorable
members and in particular my honorable
friend the member for Rutland and Milton
who is a great champion of improved
mental health that today my department
through our National Institute for
Health and Care research has agreed to
provide the funding we need for the next
stage of this app's development and I
want to pay tribute Mr Speaker to Siena
and all those other babies born
stillborn to their parents and thank all
those in this chamber who have
campaigned passionately on this
important issue Ellen Page thank you Mr
Speaker another dental practice in my
constituency recently handed back their
NHS contract when I contacted local NHS
management about the impact of this
closure they stated that the area in
question was adjudged to be well served
for NHS Dentistry practices because
there are 11 practices within a half
mile radius but the experience of my
constituents now left searching for NHS
Dental Services is that none of these
practices are accepting new NHS patients
what is the Secretary of State doing to
ensure that assessments of the
sufficiency of NHS Dental Services
reflect the real situation on the ground
and when will we see a sustainable
solution to the problems my visitors are
facing well The Honorable lady raises an
important issue and it is one of concern
across the houses we've already seen in
the exchanges that my honor friend have
answered that in part was why during the
pandemic we use 1.7 billion pounds of
funding to protect Dentistry it's why
we've got a commitment through the 3
billion a year funding of Dentistry but
we're looking at how we localize that
commissioning to get better value out of
that contract and that was the point my
honorable friend raised Murray Robinson
Mr Speaker one o'clock today patient
safety expert Dr bill kirkup will be
speaking to MPS at the whistleblowing
appg to which all colleagues are invited
it's a timely meeting following this
weekend's Newsnight program which
highlighted yet another NHS trust where
a Culture of Fear left staff unable to
speak up on patient safety concerns its
clear changes needed does my honorable
friend agree with me that supporting
whistleblowers in the NHS is crucial for
patient safety speaker my honorable
friend is so right about this I praise
her work with the appg I know a lot of
colleagues will want to attend it
whistleblowers can save lives and
improve Healthcare I've seen that my own
Constitution since she's so right to be
pressing on this Secretary of State went
straight Mr Speaker the chairman of the
conservative party claims that NHS
strikes are exactly what Vladimir Putin
wants so why isn't the health secretary
negotiating to prevent them from going
ahead
well I've seen him make this claim
across the media a number of times just
to reassure The Honorable gen
gentleman my door is open I've been very
clear with the trade unions I'm
available and available see them this
afternoon or tomorrow it is not me Mr
Speaker that said a precondition on
those talks so there's a number of
issues when I met with the trade unions
that they've raised not only pay but
around uh safety of staff and other
conditions the estate Tech and so forth
and I'm very happy to engage with the
trend unions on those points it's true
too
Mr Speaker we get the warm words about
wanting to negotiate but a government
Source brief the times last week that
his plan is to wait for public
sentiments to turn against striking
nurses saying and I quote this is going
to affect a lot of people it could have
a big impact on a lot of them and in the
end they will get fed up he knows this
winter is going to be the most difficult
the NHS has ever faced and he's using
nurses as a scapegoat to avoid the blame
that's the shameful truth isn't it
well firstly it's a bit bizarre that
department questions the best it can
manage is quote a government source and
and secondly the revelation of that
government source is that this will
affect quotes a lot of people I don't
think that comes as any surprise that's
why we regret uh the action and we're
very open to having talked the point is
he himself does not support the 19 pay
demand of the trade unions so he stands
here saying we should be talking whilst
himself not accepting their proposal
both live
there have been several changes of
ministers as we know but officials have
carried on working through these changes
so can we know what day day date and
time the long promise and overdue
Tobacco Control plan will finally be
published yeah whatever format our next
steps forward is set out in we will be
pushing forward very very quickly and
aggressively on this and this year we're
putting 35 million into NHS to support
uh services for everyone who goes in to
stop smoking with double duty on
cigarettes brought in a minimum exercise
tax women who are pregnant now routinely
get a carbon monoxide test National
campaigns like stoptober have helped now
2.1 million people quit smoking we're
also supporting a future medically
licensed vaping product of the quitting
Edge so we will be pressing forward at
the greatest speed some peace first
person to intellectual property
protections are an important way of
protecting healthcare companies
Innovations we know this robot
developments on intellectual property
can also impact the rates of individuals
limiting access to Affordable Lifesaver
essential made cool products but recent
representations has a secretary of state
Hardware College in the department for
international trade seeking Assurance is
that nothing in the proposed free trade
agreement with India where Empire
jeopardized access to Affordable
measures medicines for NHS patients in
Scotland ah you don't well I can reach
all the honorable Gentleman on that and
I I would have thought he would also
welcome the commitment the 15 billion to
20 billion increase in r d investment
the championing of life sciences that my
honorable friend the ministers for help
has been leading on and the opportunity
we have particularly to address greater
variation within the NHS by bringing
forward the Innovations from our life
um so uh industry and applying those
much quicker Alexander Stafford Mr
Speaker civil GP practices in Rolla
Valley such as hollowness Health Center
operate a policy of having to ruin the
doctorate surgery for appointments at
8am resident funds serving Place 50th or
60th and queue then the final there's no
appointments available and be told to
call back the next day this is clean not
except ways to offer appointments what
step are my honorable friends taking to
stop the current failed booking system
and to instead guarantee a system of
pre-booked appointments at all GP
surgeries
Mr Speaker this is something that we are
working on very actively as well as
supporting financial aid GPS to roll out
new and better ways of managing uh their
appointments we're also looking at what
criteria we expect from our GPS because
we already set out some moves in our
summer action plan but we will be
looking further at preventing the
lamentable situation he describes of
people being asked to ring back or held
in long-form cues is not acceptable cold
Turner the public aren't Daft Mr Speaker
they know that the backlogs in the NHS
existed well before the pandemic they
know that the NHS was already on its
knees and the novel it was this Tory
government that brought it to its needs
so why doesn't the government take up
Labor's policy of scrapping non-dom
status
use the 3.6 billion to train nurses
doctors and midwives get the NHS back on
its feet people in East stall want
nurses
not non-doms
[Music]
well the data is very clear Mr Speaker
in fact it's very Stark as to the extent
to which the backlogs is driven
predominantly by uh the pandemic and
that is why we have a program through
the X-ray investment in the Autumn
statement the 6.6 billion over the next
two years going into the NHS but also
the 2.8 billion next year and 4.7
billion the year after inter-social care
8 billion in 2024 recognizing the size
of those backlogs so we confirm the
surgical hubs the Daniel centers on the
thank you Mr dry Max with local care
providers last Friday and two main
points they raised with me were concerns
over energy costs and covid in Care
Homes they were Keen to see their
nursing staff vaccinated with residents
all at the same time whilst I recognize
this happens in some places can we look
at this becoming the norm throughout the
country
thank you Mr Speaker my girlfriend makes
a really important point I'll say to her
the NHS is strongly encouraging local
vaccination teams to vaccinate staff as
well as residents when they visit Care
Homes this should be normal practice I'm
very happy to look into it if it's not
happening in her area and actually I'd
like to take this opportunity to
encourage any health or social care
worker who hasn't had their covert or
food job this winter to please go ahead
and get one fly back up thank you Mr
Speaker parents have become an
increasingly worried about the
prevalence of strep high at this moment
in time it's the time of year when
parents are going to serve children that
have high temperatures and sore throats
and so concern is likely to be very high
there's also concerns about availability
of antibiotics so does the Secretary of
State believe that this is the moment
where the government needs to make a
make a statement and show clear
leadership to recarm people down and
reassure them about the situation uh
thank you Mr Speaker we did hold a
cross-party briefing for MP last night
on strep a we want to reassure parents
if their children do have symptoms and
they are concerned to seek help GPS
already a e departments are ready and
also we have directors of Public Health
proactively going to schools where there
are cases there is no shortage of
antibiotics want to reassure people on
that and we're keeping an eye on that on
a daily basis
thank you very much Mr Speaker the East
Lancashire CDC already includes Burnley
hospital and as part of that we're
opening to do endoscopy rooms in the
spring but myself residents and the
trust know that the local hospital local
hospital can do even more to reduce the
covid backlog with the right government
investment so would you agree to meet
with me to discuss phase nine of the
hospital's development which would bring
a brand new Radiology Suite well I think
mondal friend for his uh question he's a
strong Champion for Burnley and I
congratulate Bernie General teaching
Hospital on the incredible Innovative
work that they are doing he's right CDC
rollout UH 60 or 91 out of 160 is
tremendous effort but we do want to go
further and I'd be delighted to meet my
little friend to discuss his plans
further
last week the first Minister away as
Mark Drakeford said the pillar boards
are not being funded at the level that
we believe that they should be funding
and the ways to see general secretary
said unless we've got a fear of funding
settlement for Wales we're going to
struggle going forward so Mr Speaker
when will this government listen to
Welsh government and the Welsh trade
unions and provide a proper funding pay
award for NHS staff that they deserve
um I'm simply direct her to the Bonnet
consequentials as a former Chief
secretary and haven't had those
discussions with the Welsh Finance
ministers you should know that actually
Wales gets significantly more funding
per head of population than England and
I hope she would welcome the fact that
through the extra 6.6 billion in the
Autumn statement uh the first Minister
will have a significant uplift for him
to decide how he wishes to spend that
money Mahendra thank you Mr Speaker I
was recently contacted by Amanda in my
beautiful constitutions Southwest
Hertfordshire whose 88 year old mother
had fallen in a flat and unfortunately
broken her hip after a five hour wait
two calls to 999 her mother is still
laying on the floor
once they arrived at AME Amanda and her
mother waited several more hours before
being seen to can my right Uncle friend
reassure the house that he's doing
everything possible to find a solution
to the system-wide issue
well I think he raises an extremely
important case and I'm very happy to
meet with him to discuss this further
because I think it is a concerning case
and I'm Keen to engage with him on it
thank you Mr Speaker my honorable friend
the shadow Minister for public health
touched on
um the health inequalities later but I
did earlier but I didn't hear the health
secretary recommitting to publishing the
wife the deadline does he understand
that the cost of living crisis and
poverty is leading to Greater Health
inequalities and action is needed
urgently now and can he recommit to that
white paper being published
so so we are absolutely committed to
addressing Health inequalities and
rather than simply looking at 10 years
time what we're looking at it is what
are the immediate actions we can do
because what matters
about weight papers from the bench
opposite well I'm interested in this
immediate delivery what is it we can be
doing now rather than speculating about
what he's done in 10 years time
Mr Speaker we're seeing a sadly increase
in suicide rates across the country and
in 2012 the government then published a
10-year cross-government Suicide
Prevention plan and earlier this year
the the government under the leadership
of my right honorable friend the the
member for Oxbridge committed to a new
uh 10-year plan that will be published
before the start of 2023. there is no
sign of that cross-government 10-year
Suicide Prevention plan at this point
but maybe I'm wrong maybe the government
is about to publish this because I know
so much of the work on this has been
done already so can I ask my right
honorable friend to show that he takes
Suicide Prevention very seriously and
that to publish this plan as soon as
possible
well can I thank my right honorable
friend and pay tribute to all his work
uh in this area he has driven this
agenda forward I want to reassure him
that we are looking at that he will
understand that we have had some changes
in recent weeks but I want to assure him
that this is a tackling uh the issue of
suicide as a high priority and we were
making an announcement shortly Dr Rupert
thank you Mr
from three thousand to nine thousand in
the last decade put in plans approved
for expansion but NHS Estates now won't
cough up what is the government doing to
support doctors in inadequate premises
they can't expand their patient lists
what is he doing to help them expand and
modernize in the current climate
kind of activity done by GPS as The
Honorable then your nose is up it's
about seven percent up uh in October
compared to the previous uh year we are
looking very actively at the way that
Capital works and the contributions of
section 106 and also of the local ICB as
well to make sure that as well as having
extra doctors the 2 300 extra doctors
and the 21 000 extra staff they also
have good facilities to work in Sports
speaker access to Dentistry is an acute
issue for West Oxfordshire could
ministers explain what they're doing to
help rural areas like mine and can we
meet to discuss it further
well Mr Speaker I've mentioned the fact
that the number of NHS dentists was up
two percent 2.3 last year uh we've
talked about the extra 50 million and
the reforms to the contract that we've
already made but we will go further and
particularly we do want to address those
areas particularly rural areas where uh
we need to get more provision urgently
speaking of the chair
chronic conditions such as asthma
diabetes and even serious mental health
conditions refusing sick notes because
they can't afford time off work what
discussions has the secretary of state
had with cabinet colleagues about the
adequacy of status recipient during this
course of living crisis well I I refer
to the audience statement where my
writing my friend the chancellor set out
a wide range of support packages to to
help those with cost of living across
the United Kingdom including the cost of
energy and that is part of wider
discussions that we have on a regular
basis with the treasury reliance
Mr Speaker the pandemic has had a
devastating effect on the number of
people waiting for treatment in 2019
there were 54 women waiting more than a
year to see a gynecologist that number
is now more than 40 000. what is my
right number friend doing to reduce this
weight
will Mr Speaker to the earlier question
the gentleman's no longer in his place
but that's a good illustration that the
the challenge the country faces in terms
of the backlogs is very much driven by
the pandemic consequences and what we
are doing is working with senior people
like Jim Mackey and Professor Tim Riggs
and they get it right first time to look
at the patient Pathways how we use our
Diagnostics our surgical herbs and
streamline the way we get services to
patients where those backlogs are built
up I'm in Robinson Mr Speaker and
grateful to the minister for the answers
she gave the honorable member for Alpha
meringue strep a this morning tragically
we learned that a five-year-old girl
died yesterday in Belfast a P2 pupil at
Black Mountain Primary School with strep
a and so on grateful for her encouraging
equipment at the in fact I'll show the
penicillin is available antibiotics are
available but can she ensure that our
Public Health agencies across this
United Kingdom cooperate with one
another and an additional resource is
required that will be made available
uh well can I thank uh right on the
gentleman I'm very sorry obviously to
hear about the the tragic case
um in Northern Ireland this is a you
know we want to reassure people that uh
while there is a slightly higher number
of cases and will be usual for this time
of year uh the the um are you know on
top of this and are not concerned that
there's a wider outbreak than would be
expected but we do want to encourage
parents that if they are concerned that
their children are not responding to get
um help as soon as possible antibiotics
are available
um and there are local directors of
Public Health should be coordinating
local activity but we are if our only
concerns do come and see me
thank you Mr Speaker on Saturday I
visited chalkboard Grange a brilliant
new care home in picturesque Leon sea
but they are struggling to recruit due
to the guidance that all care workers
should wear face masks would the
Secretary of State give them the best
Christmas present ever and remove that
word should to can or May and put them
in charge of their own infection control
I thank my honorable member and it's
very good to hear that she was visiting
a local care home and what she's heard
from staff I have also heard from staff
because while face mocks are important
for infection control we also know that
they have downsides like making
communication harder I have asked for
updated Public Health advice on the use
of mastering Care Homes and I look
forward to updating honorable members
and the social care sector on the
guidance on that shortly Daisy Cooper
speaker my constituent is a victim of
sexual misconduct by a medical
professional but they can't challenge
that professional's Fitness to practice
because of the five-year rule the GMC
wants the five-year rule to be scrapped
the government consulted on whether to
get rid of the five-year rule more than
a year ago could Minister please say
whether it is the government's intention
to scrap The Five-Year Rule and would
she meet with me so I can discuss how
important it is that the GMC can explore
whether a potentially dangerous Medical
Professional who is still practicing may
be unfit to do so
uh can I thank normal ladies uh
campaigning on this issue is a very
serious issue I'm very happy to meet
with her I would suggest we also meet
with a patient safety commissioner
Henrietta Hughes to discuss this further
could the executive State give an
undertaking to the house but no NHS or
social Care Facility will be
decommissioned and used to house Asylum
Seekers
a in northamptonshire and being the rest
of the country
not aware of any proposal on the lines
to which he eludes but on his earlier
Point as I say I'm very happy to meet
with him to discuss the issue in some
sort of step down care and I'm sure any
other concerns he has there'll be an
opportunity to discuss those at the same
time I'm a little bit very much Mr
Speaker my constituent Margaret cramen
is a full-time carer for her daughter
throughout the pandemic she was denied
respite care now the Care setting
insists on testing for visitors and mask
wearing for staff cause and distress to
some of the young people being cared for
who rely on vital facial recognition
nearly all other covert guidance has
been reviewed yet the guidance for
respite care Remains the Same why are
carers and those they're careful always
an afterthought for this government
I thought I'd Point The Honorable member
towards the answer I just gave my
honorable friend a moment ago on the
question specifically of face mask where
I have asked for updated guidance for
the social care sector on the use of
face masks I recognize the difficulties
they cause for instance in communication
and I'm looking forward to be able to
give an update to honorable members and
the sector on this very shortly
because what I say is a minister made of
geographic variation and access to
Innovative liver cancer treatments such
as selective internal radiation therapy
well it's a brilliant question on which
to close because I think one of the
things all the house should be hugely
interested in is how we are adopting
Innovation quicker and how we are
industrializing that Innovation across
the NHS as a whole as opposed to in
silence now there's something we are
particularly focused on uh within the
department it is a key priority and I'm
very happy to speak to the Scottish
government and others as to how to we
work together on that
that completes the question
Gregory Campbell thank you Mr Speaker
during last week's debate on Northern
Ireland and the reduction of mla's pay I
raised the fact that absentation for an
MPS have received 10 million pounds in
various alliances over the last 10 years
alone the Northern Ireland office
Minister The Honorable member for
Wickham said he didn't recognize the
figure I asked the House of Commons
library to research and they confirmed
my figure as correct I then furnished
this to both the minister and the leader
of the House who is responsible for
bringing a resolution to end this
scandalous anomaly where MPS whose
leader has said they have no business in
Westminster continue to receive millions
of pounds to do no business in
Westminster has the leader indicated to
you that she plans to bring a resolution
to end this scandalous anomaly yeah yeah
the country is no but I'm also grateful
to the honorable member for giving
notice of his bunch of water as he will
know I'm not responsible for the
accuracy of the contributions of
ministers or other members if the narrow
has been made the record should be
corrected and then the event The
Honorable members certainly put his
points on the record right let us now
come to the 10 minute rule Bill Stephen
Bonner
Mr Speaker I beg to move that leave be
given to bring in a bow to make
provision about employment rights
including the right to request more
predictable terms and conditions of work
commend the definition of worker and
forth connected purposes yeah yeah
fairness compassion and equality these
are not only the basics it should be a
Ford they teach in every working person
across these islands but also how we can
measure the effectiveness of governments
upon those theyself the covid-19
pandemic has highlighted the many
failings Within